welcome back subaru of las vegas who is
the sponsor of this next segment had
something very special arrive at the
dealership so of course i had to go
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
hey burton casey where you been i was
running late i figured the best way to
get down here my friend michelle she's a
race car driver hi michelle souped up
wrx the best way to get down here this
is a classic
thanks michelle appreciate it
so that's a race car yeah i'm here today
to see something roomy and rugged can
you show me i absolutely can i've got
just the car for you beautiful let's go
let's go all right it's good to see man
whoa
burton i love it isn't it beautiful yes
this is the all-new 2022 subaru outback
wilderness gorgeous tell me more about
it nine and a half inches of ground
clearance you can go off-road with this
thing is this a camera here that's a
camera so you can see boulders that are
in front of you perfect a skid plate
underneath here to protect your
undercarriage what do we got here so
you've got a tow hooks that are behind
these panels so you're going to tow
people that are out yeah you're going to
help people that aren't in a subaru get
out
and with anti-glare anti-glare so you
don't have the sun shining in your face
when you're driving oh my gosh real
high-powered fog lights this looks this
looks different yeah so you know when
you're off-road you're spinning your
tires sometimes and rocks and dirt are
flying you need to protect your paint
wow isn't that cool tires much beefier
than before all terrain tires and rims
designed for the off-road i am a fan of
the wilderness what do we have here so
that is for a rooftop tent you got
you've got mounting places right up
there for a tent so you go camping up
top yes this is awesome burton the first
thing i noticed sitting on the inside of
the wilderness the seats so comfortable
they are and that material did you see
it yeah that's called startex it is a
very durable washable material let's
talk about the dash this is a gorgeous
view i mean it's amazing and if you look
at the center stack there you can see it
says x mode this has an enhanced x mode
which is subaru's
system to help you get off the road you
can see you can go to snow or dirt
normal or even deep snow and mud subaru
you guys have so much going on one thing
i do love about you guys is you're
always giving back to the community what
do you guys have lined up first for the
month of august well for the subaru love
promise pillar this month it's subaru
loves learning and you know we have
adopted a classroom at the judith steele
elementary school and we are donating
ten thousand dollars to the school so
they can take care of their kids and
their their educators and and also we've
got a great thing working uh
with the read to me book drive going on
yeah we're asking people to come on in
donate monday through saturday they can
be here 8 am to 8 pm new and gently used
books you guys are always giving back
that's why we love you so much thank you
so much for your time today my ride she
left any chance of uh getting a ride
home okay come on let's go buddy i
always appreciate it
visit subaru of las vegas at 6455 roy
hornway or call them at
702-495-2100 or visit them at subaru of
las vegas dot com and they have a
special offer for you zero percent
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2021 models
now through august 31st